I've been using the Vision Pro for about
a week now and it is incredible but
there are some major issues that stand
in the way so in this video I'm going to
focus on that and if you guys can see
right over here I'm not wearing the
Vision Pro like most people wear it now
I did take that off and I'm actually
working on a full day of wearing div
Vision Pro so if you guys didn't see
that video yet make sure to check it out
down below cuz I'll explain how this
work works and the first issue is the
field of view now with VR headsets in
general you do kind of get a ski goggle
like effect and with the Vision Pro it
could actually be a little bit worse
than the other ones but what we
discovered is it really depends on your
seal and the band that you're wearing on
there and because of that I've actually
walked and bumped into things like the
door my tripod and that does get a
little annoying but once again check out
the other video for this now the second
and I think the biggest issue with the
Vision Pro is the camera quality we have
12 sensors all around but only these two
right here are the ones that actually
give you the camera feed and you guys
have seen my footage uh previously it
does not look great and then wearing it
it might actually look slightly worse
now it is the best pass through compared
to any other VR or ar headset but it
still looks nothing like the real world
and the crazy thing is when you open up
an app or something that's rendered the
quality is just so incredible because
the displays are so incredible but we
just need better cameras and one thing
that I would love is to be able to have
a zoom feature for example something at
a distance with small text you can't
really read it but I would love to be
able to have a zoom lens where I can
literally just enlarge or enhance
something and that would actually help
use ability compared to even your
regular eyes now adding on to that the
screen recording also doesn't look great
and unfortunately if you're watching a
YouTube video you cannot tell the
quality compared to what I see in the
depth perception so you really have to
try it for yourself but be warned if you
go try it out you're going to be very
tempted to buy one at least on a payment
plan if you can't afford the full amount
now with that the cameras also have an
issue with minimal focusing distance if
you try to hold something up close it
gets really blurry because that's how
cameras work and so that's issue that
you don't have in real life now the next
thing that affects a lot of Mac users is
the ability to only have a one single
screen um if you're going to be using it
it sometimes it'd be nice to have
multiple apps open dual virtual screens
other platforms use it but right now
apple is limiting that now with that
when your keyboard pops up well you can
only use your index fingers and it's
really slow so you want to connect
another keyboard and I wish they would
give us the ability to use Swipe just
like on your iPhone that would speed
things up quite a bit now the next issue
that I ran into is that the tracking of
the hands and the UI is so good you
actually start getting lost in this
world and then in the real world I
actually had multiple times where I
tried to pinch something and stretch it
out like my TV or my monitor here at
work and then you realize well you can't
do that in reality that is how good the
whole system is now the next issue is
with the battery now a lot of people
were worried about this whole headset
being uncomfortable because it is heavy
but I've had no issues with that
especially with the better strap the
more annoying thing is the battery
itself it's large it has to Output a lot
of power and this cable is also very
thick and can become Twisted it's
attached over here it's not as
comfortable as I would like um and so
thankfully I did get this clip I thought
it wouldn't be worth it but you can
actually wear it as a strap so instead
of having to be in your pocket kind of
getting tangled up I'm going to try it
out right after this video and I'll put
it into my full day usage and we'll see
how that goes now the next thing that
stood out to me is when I was doing my 8
hour productivity uh video I was trying
to set up a bunch of different
applications and unfortunately if you
have stuff layered even slightly
overlapping the screen will become gray
unless you focus on it and I wish that I
could have something slightly blocking
without having extra good amount of room
and to keep everything in Focus but the
next issue is a more serious one and
it's something that we expected and that
is the fact that certain applications
games even like Google Apps and YouTube
they are missing now of course you can
use your web browser but the video
quality could be worse you might not be
able to download videos like you can in
an app um and that's something we have
to wait for now people complain why
don't these developers just allow their
iPad apps to be used but then if you
look at Apple even themselves they did
not put Final Cut the iPad version on
the Vision Pro and same with other Apple
apps so you can't really blame other
developers it's just going to take more
time now with that you can do some
seriously cool FaceTiming uh with the
personas um Ben and I were messing
around with it it is absolutely
incredible but you cannot take phone
calls on the Vision Pro so I would get
phone calls from different people for my
wife and it just would not come through
and then you pull your iPhone out you
have to switch over to that and
unfortunately with that because you have
the headset on your face ID doesn't work
it doesn't really link anyway like that
now here's another thing I ran into with
apps that want to use face ID well with
the headset you are not going to be
logging in and sometimes it takes a
couple times before it lets you do a
password some apps just don't want to do
it and you are kind of stuck I wish
there was a way for it to know and kind
of talk and the lock with each other and
even better it'd be so cool if I can
connect my iPhone as an app so certain
apps and certain things I want to do on
there I could see it and control it
instead of having to pull it out and use
it as an additional device and with that
comes touch control I mentioned it's so
great to be able to use your eyes and
touch but when you connect your Mac you
bring it close you can't use touch and
also if you walk away you pull the
screen outside like I did I can't
connect to it unless I have a keyboard
and a mouse and then you're dealing with
Bluetooth range it'd be so cool if they
allowed us to use your iPad your iPhone
or your Mac and at least be able to
access it even if it wouldn't be an
optimal experience instead of reverting
back to the old school ways now one
thing that I forgot to add but I'm
adding it now is the travel mode you
would think that I would allow it to not
have to track things if you're walking
around but unfortunately things are
glitchy they move around everywhere and
I would love to have a feature where
it's kind of like a heads up display
where you can put up your navigation
maps in one area maybe messages and
you're walking around doing stuff and
the windows are just staying there so
you can constantly see them and they're
useful instead of just glitching out
moving around and staying if you're on
the go so I think they could definitely
fix that in a software update and I
think the last one that I can mention to
this it's a positive one but you don't
really want to take it off it is so cool
there's so many things that you could do
that you can't do in the real world
where it's just fun it's awesome and it
could be beneficial um so I'm
unfortunately it's designed to be used
in certain places where you can't just
walk and use a heads up display um so
that's a little bit of a limitation but
overall it is just so much better than I
expected even with the limitations it's
an awesome product and it is only going
to get better so you guys let me know
your thoughts on the Vision Pro so far
if you picked one up and if you saw my
24-hour video what you think of this
setup right here click that Circle above
to subscribe check out one of those
great videos right over there this been
Max and I'll see you in the next one all
right back at it
again going to the office trying to not
get
hit what's up guys hey what's
up doing it yes started